[Music]
welcome everyone
to scott today for luradu the rule is
simpler
i think i ran out of intros i don't know
now
let's just jump into it that's right
kids
that's what we do here on this channel
has t-series beat us yes
first of all round of applause i thought
it was the end game last week but we're
still in it
and we're still kicking it now i'm a day
ahead now just a day ahead
so it would be very awkward while i make
this video very happy and very cheerful
and then somehow t
series has passed out of nowhere i mean
they're they're calling in the
cavalry and all kinds of all these
indian celebrities going
hey i'm not paid to do this and i'm not
paid to say this
but uh subscribe to tv series oh and
there's definitely not a gun to my head
but uh subscribe to t-series look at
this you can make
india win i don't care they're calling
the indian celebrities
pathetic okay i barely relied on help
from
anyone now uh this got a little
sidetracked we're supposed to laugh at
memes but uh yeah okay let's just jump
into it okay
warning guys warning captain marvel
spoilers
coming right up if you have it
ricardo ricardo i've never seen so many
people being pissed off
about me raiding a meme 10 out of 10. it
is
the meme that keeps giving i absolutely
love it ricardo
lives forever
ricardo immortal the immortal son
of the immortal god ricardo his name
will echo in
for centuries and above next meme this
is getting weird
oh wait i've already shown this but it's
a ricardo meme and it's all god they're
beautiful
take my heart ricardo take it you it's
yours
you gotta legit put a bar here like
anything with ricardo gets demonetized
if you show his dong so i apologize for
that by the way that was a note for my
editor but you deserve to know
she's answering effing nobody she's
having answering the phones at walmart
no i don't work here but the phone's
ringing and ringing and i know how it
feels to be on that other end and nobody
answers
it but we're like we're still waiting
for somebody you want to hang up and try
back
look at the girl
oh you're welcome have a good night
that's kind of sweet i like that walmart
we need to find whoever's responsible
when you definitely heard a noise in
your house but you're too afraid to turn
around and look
you can turn any sad day to a happy one
look at that dog it's absolutely
terrified
okay i feel like that could be me i feel
bad for this eight-year-old fallen
brother
he doesn't deserve this ridicule that
will follow him for the rest of his life
i just realized i haven't had the green
screen filled what the hell is this
fun wait oh my god
very nice moving on have you lost the
challenge oh my god
i haven't even been paying attention to
my health party
looks like i'm fine have you ordered
your gx4 by the way enter the code
pewdiepie to get 10 off pretty good deal
moving on no you
oh god oh wow
i'm so tired i'll laugh at anything this
is stupid
he's not mad it's not mad if it was matt
you know he would have won
that's right go back come here
get out stay look at me no shirt why are
you still looking at me
look at the ground yeah hey look up that
shirt yeah look up yes
look at your own face why you never
looked at your own face
just the ultimate meme of this would
have been if you pulled out a mirror yes
sir
just a little feedback for the future
moving on looks like we're off to the
west coast to find some more leaks
let's see what we can find
phil what are you doing in minecraft
phil swift be back later
damn phil is living the high line did
you guys see this
flex seal did their part sub to
pewdiepie
phil swift declares that in order to
assist pewdiepie
he will saw t-series in half thank you
phil sweet
very cool
of course it happened i think i think
this is a reflection of how
like oh my god oh my god
watch out no ela
i don't know about that one not a
scatter from me at least i'm sorry
try next time maybe but it turns out i
am
undefeated in this challenge i'm scared
to do florida i just can't lose
it's crazy pewdiepie versus t
[Music]
series
no
oh my god
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that is absolutely beautiful
and that makes everything worth it
that's hilarious god damn it
how do i look like okay
okay selena gomez
i mean both human good joke felix thank
you
next meme everyone white kids with do
rags on their heads
why are you about to do it what's that
you got wade you're getting away
i'm getting away see this is what
happens in the suburbs
[Laughter]
black culture to another level look at
that
you're waiting for where are your ways
let me see check them check them show
them see those waves son
wave check look at this
[Laughter]
this is crazy oh my god you like your
way
oh you're like look at this
we got their ways i won't get i don't
get seasick
that's good good meme man we had some
good lives today don't we
oh god it keeps going oh god are they
going to add another layer
i expect when i ask for a freaking bro
now this is the kind of real enthusiasm
when i ask for a profit just kidding
you broke your screen for nothing
how is your screen not broken yet
pounded real
for once final give me your hardest
broken you're gonna
ah damn that felt good
i'll buy you a new monitor share it i'm
sorry
[Music]
nice that was beautiful
i want to hear that again
[Music]
nice this is great it just makes me
smile
good thing this isn't try not to smile
challenge
what do you see what does he see
ricardo
hell yes ricardo i love him
it's beautiful home
i see her god damn
what's with the swedish crossover on the
ricardo means like
boston on and then now they played uh
obviously i we can't show the audio but
it weirds me out a little bit
that's it for me for now i hope you guys
enjoyed this episode smash like
subscribe and it
always this is not the real merch guys
this is not the merch you have to buy
this is the merch i know it's a bit
disappointing
compared to what okay this is the new
birch check it out
and i see you guys tomorrow bye what
tuber
simulator is becoming relevant
no no don't leave
no please sponsor eagle please do
something
yes
ah this game is still relevant
god dammit
[Music]